[موسيقى]
لطالم ارتبطت بعض الحركات كالنظر الى
اليسار او فرك الانف بطريقه معينه بالشخص
الكاذب لكن الخبراء لهم راي اخر فالشخص
الذي ينظر الى اليسار او يفرك انفه يمكن
ان يكون بالفعل متلاعبا او مخادعا لكن فقط
اذا كانت هذه الايماءات غير اعتياديه
بالنسبه له فبحسب تقرير نشر في موقع فان
التفسير لتلك الكلمات والاشارات ينطبق اذا
كانت غير معتاده بنسبه لذلك الشخص الدراسه
تقول ان استخدام لغه الجسد لتحديد
المخادعين يستغرق وقتها ودراسه ومعرفه
جيده للشخص نفسه لذا من السهل دائما
اكتشاف التلاعب عندما ياتي من شخص تعرفه
جيدا وعلى ذرايا جيدا بلغته جسده وعند
ملاحظه تغييرها يسهل كشف الكذب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هل هناك بالفعل اشارات ايماءات معينه في
الشخص اذا شفتها تكشف انه مخادع او غير
صوتك
مهم او حتى الناس العاديين في ثلاثه اشياء
اساسيه اللي هي باللغه الانجليزيه تعبير
تعبير العين الدقيقه وتعبير الوجه الدقيقه
وتعبير الجسد الدقيقه المايكروفون
وهي تفاصيل كثير دقيقه تعكس الحاله لا
واعيه للشخص امامك اهو وبالذات انه هو عم
يحكي من النيرفز السيستم تبعه فلما هو مخ
بيطرب او بيصير اي فيه افكار سواء كذب او
مش صديق او في مش ضروري كذب ممكن عم يتهرب
من الاجابه او بده يعمل شيء معين فبتلاقي
كل هذه الاشياء بتظهر على تعبيره وهو
بيصير فيه تفاصيل بنسميها التسريبات لغه
الجسد عمار هناك
الرجل
همم
العقل البشري العقل اليمين مسؤول عن
الابداع والعقل اليسار هذه مفيد مشاهديكي
بهذه المعلومات المهمه جدا بس منبه
زوجاتنا كثير
يستعملوه الحياه فالعقل اليمين مسؤول عن
الابداع والعقل اليسار المسؤول عن التركيز
فانا لما بينظر الشخص وهو بيكلمك
فبالتالي عم يعمل ابداع الكلب بنعمل
عقله اليسار فبالتالي هو عم بيركز
بالاستجلاب ذاكره معينه للاستجلاب همم اي
شيء من راسه او من تجاربه او المخابراته
بيكون هو عم بيركز بتعرف انه هو عم يصدق
اكثر انه هو عم يستحضر شيء موجود عقله
[موسيقى]